the Queen has given her blessing for the
couple to quit life as members of the
royal family but now we're learning that
one key player was left out of Monday's
meeting where all the details were
hashed out a royal source confirms to ET
that Meghan Markel did not call in to
discuss her and Harry's future within
the British monarchy only Harry met with
his grandmother Queen Elizabeth father
Prince Charles and brother Prince
William while his wife and son Archie
were miles away on Vancouver Island in
Canada the source says that in the end
the Sussex is decided that it wasn't
necessary for the Duchess to join the
Prince of Wales and Prince Harry arrived
around 1120 we believe that they took
lunch with the Queen and that the
Sandringham summit as it's being called
started at 2:00 o'clock Prince William
only arrived 15 minutes we understand
before that meeting and talks finally
came to a close at 5:00 when the Queen
stopped everything for teatime fueling
speculation that Harry's relationship
with William is at an all-time low
following the Sussex 'iz announcement to
step back as senior members of the royal
family
the brothers address the rumours in a
joint statement on Monday quote despite
clear denials a false story ran in a UK
newspaper today speculating about the
relationship between the Duke of Sussex
and the Duke of Cambridge four brothers
who care so deeply about the issues
surrounding mental health the use of
inflammatory language in this way is
offensive and potentially harmful
we're brothers we'll always be brothers
and for William it was business as usual
on Tuesday the royal was photographed
using British sign language as he
honored a famous deaf TV host for the
impact he's had on the community Harry
is expected to attend his first public
event later this week Harry has an
engagement coming up this Thursday we
understand he's going to honor that and
he will fly to Canada very soon
afterwards this of course is part of the
period of transition the Queen spelled
out in her statement after Monday's
meeting according to the monarch the
Sussex is was
spend time in Canada and the UK as final
decisions about their future are reached
in the coming days it feels incredibly
personal to me
it feels quite sad as well you get the
impression that the Queen during this
meeting probably tried as hard as she
possibly could to pups encourage Megan
and Harry to reconsider a source tells
ET that the biggest argument right now
is over money adding quote Megan wants
more flexibility to work again and the
couple wants to be able to earn a living
similar to when Harry was in the
military he felt great fulfilment in his
military career it's very easy to to
completely forget about Who I am when
I'm in the Army I am one of the guys I
don't get treated any differently our
source says that the Sussex is would
like to have a model like the Clintons
or Obamas where they can do meaningful
work while making a living all you need
to do is focus focus on being real and
focus on being the people that we are
and standing up for what we believe in
in fact Megan has already reportedly
signed a voice-over deal with Disney
this is a big deal this is reshaping the
future of the House of Windsor
it's reshaping the future of the
monarchy it is accelerating at a pace
that I don't think any of us thought we
would see
[Music]